NASA says it has received more than 800
reports of unidentified flying objects
from around the world since 1996 but
here's the thing almost all of those
sightings are easily explained but
around two to five percent of them are
actual Mysteries now for the first time
the agency investigating these UFOs held
a public meeting revealing its research
videos like these capture the hundreds
of unidentified aerial phenomena or UAP
sightings each year
now an independent team formed by NASA
is addressing how and why it's
investigating the incidents the presence
of uaps raises concerns about the safety
of our skies in the group's first public
meeting Wednesday experts stress the
need for more high quality observations
to uncover the truth in fact if I were
to summarize
in one line what I feel we've learned
it's we need high quality data the panel
said stigmas leads to people being
reluctant to report sightings and
harassment for scientists investigating
them but many events that are studied
can be explained the environment that we
fly in space or you know an atmospheric
flight very very conducive to optical
illusions retired astronaut Scott Kelly
has spent more than 500 Days in space I
would see things and I was like oh
that's really not behaving like it
should and every single time when I
would look at it long enough I would
realize that it was atmospheric lensing
and because of variations in the
atmosphere it made the trajectory look
like it wasn't going in a straight line
the panel did not completely rule out
the possibility of extraterrestrials we
haven't found life beyond Earth yet
right I mean let's be clear about this
we haven't found it yet
but we're looking the 16-member group
aims to release its official report by
the end of July
as long as I can remember I feel like
there has been some disinformation out
there that has led people astray when it
comes to what we actually know about
UFOs some people think it's ridiculous
some people are convinced they're out
there and the government's covering it
up uh but this matters for National
Security because if some other country
has a an aerial vehicle that is better
than ours they want to know right that's
another way that this can be
non-identified flying object I do think
they're out there I believe so I really
do what about you Tony I do no I I I I I
mean I don't definitively
I I know things Tony I know people no
but I do there's a different dinners
than I do
I do think they're out there